each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
and today we have with us James heusen
from University of Texas and Austin
talking a little bit about some work
that you've been doing investigating the
role of software hand play should play
in academic reputation very relevant to
stand or that we're doing here on so
well case so thanks very much Alex so
it's my pleasure to be here this morning
today I'm going to be talking about
joint work with Jim herbst lab at
Carnegie Mellon and we're going to be
talking about software work in science
and how it interacts with the scientific
reputation system so I mean to kick off
software is increasingly a really big
deal in the practice of science and you
know we kind of knew that going into
this work but but we're constantly blown
away by the amount of software work that
scientists are doing in the conduct of
their science and in their larger
collaborations so there's a survey by
our Hannah at all and they found that
scientists are spending between thirty
or forty percent of their time thirty
percent actually kind of writing
software and maybe forty percent for
other people you know using software in
the conduct of their work right
obviously the agenda for cyber
infrastructure that's big at the NSF and
other funding agencies essentially says
that using new computational methods
especially software we can change change
the scalar which we do science and
change the efficiency and effectiveness
and innovativeness in which we do
science and it's also the case I thought
this was quite interesting in in biology
and so here we have this is Giga base
pairs and this is a log scale cost right
the cost of collecting data is staying
approximately the same the cost of then
analyzing that data is shooting through
the roof right servers get this is you
know close to an exponential rise and
those are numbers based on ec2 figures
just as a comparison basis and so what
this essentially says is at least in
biology is getting cheaper relatively
cheaper to collected by
but then the more data you have in the
bigger database you have to compare it
against the more permutations you have
to compare and the more computationally
expensive it gets and the more relevant
you know good effective software is to
science so this this raises essentially
a science policy challenge which is how
can how can we improve scientific
software which isn't to say it's doing a
terrible job I'm not saying you know I'm
here from software engineering and I'm
here to help and you should have a
personal software practice that may be
true but we know that the republic of
science works in the ways that it works
and and that i'm scientists produced a
lot of really good software so the
question is how can we look at these
different aspects like if correctness
efficiency reproducibility and
innovativeness and come up with policies
that promote those in in ways that are
called with how we do science today and
as you'll see that that we've got some
ideas when looking forward to speaking
to people in the group here about how we
tie in different types of software
contributions by scientists into the
existing reputation system but today I'm
going to be talking about a specific
study about modularity and software and
so this is really a candidate policy for
trying to improve the development of
scientific software and so modularity is
is I think people who build software
relatively familiar with the idea that
if you can split the problem up into
chunks that are that keep similar
functionality close together and reduce
unnecessary interaction between
different parts of the software base
then not only can you get software that
is easier to develop and easier to test
but also organizationally it's easier
then to have people from different areas
work on and develop that software
because they can work inside those
different modules and so this makes
modularity as a system for designing and
innovation ecosystem a really appealing
policy idea so what do we know about
modular of modularity as a way of
organizing innovation so this is great
great work by baldwin and clock out of
how the business school go back and look
at the IBM 360
our system way back in the early days
where we took what was a monolithic
system the old IBM systems and broke it
up into modules the computer
architecture broke it up into modules
and then made other groups able to do
things like sell a hard drive that would
plug into the unit and then and that's
what gives us the commodity computer
systems of today right and what that
means is that different people can sell
different types of modules or provide
different types of modules and you can
do design experiments that are separate
from the rest of the system but
integrated with it which let you find
unexpectedly great ways to do different
parts of the system and but the this
literature has been largely developed in
the for-profit literature right where
people are really thinking about
different companies that are going to
sell different components or in or
situations where a system integrator is
going to pay contractors to develop
different components and then put them
together and part of what I'm going to
talk about today is why doing it with
money is different than doing it with
reputation and that's what ties back to
the scholarly literature but we've also
talked about this in the open source
arena where where modularity has been
called an architecture of participation
which is to say that when things are
broken up in good ways it's easier for
volunteers and people from outside to
come in and work on small parts of the
code and so that's additional work by
baldwin clarke and also our western
omani and this is say this is pretty
appealing in the scientific context we
want to improve the software
collectively drawing on the sort of
communalism of science and the ability
hopeful ability to work together always
with all starlix do it next to it
remembering that science is also
competitive then perhaps an architecture
would be useful amol modular
architecture of useful so there's some
good evidence that you can actually do
this you can take an existing software
project remodulate the code base and
change the way the development around
that code base is organized and so Alan
McCormick did a study looking at
comparing Linux and netscape and so when
nets when netscape went to the mozilla
foundation
it had been developed relatively
in-house and unsurprisingly had a
relatively monolithic codebase right
intentionally they wanted to design that
to reduce the coupling between the
different units in order to attract
outside participation volunteers and
they were actually able to do that and
this paper shows that it at least is
credibly linked to the growth of
volunteer participation in Firefox
together with a campaign to bring people
in all right so that's kind of that's
kind of the research setting here sorry
that's the research background the
research setting is a study of blast and
so blast is a crucial piece of
scientific software it is it really does
look ups against DNA databases okay so
for many years when biologists have
produced a sequence from an organism
they've taken it and put it in GenBank
which is a public publicly accessible
database with all these sequences so
let's say you dig up some ants out of
the ground in Guatemala that's one of
one of the people I studied to do and
and you know that there's also a bunch
of microbes and things in there you can
then shotgun so you can sequence that
whole chunk and look at a special gene
called 16s and compare that to the
database and get back our best guess
identifications of all the organisms
that are in you know you're literally
felt ecological system how do you do
that where you do it with the version of
optical string optical are optimal
string matching which is implemented in
the blast software all right so it's a
hugely important piece of software as
you can imagine and in 2003 the paper
that that argued that it was the third
most cited scientific paper ever okay so
in some situations scientific software
ends up really well sited we've talked
about that a little bit later as well so
in 2008 this software code underwent a
full refactoring to move to a more
modular architecture so the study here
looks at innovation before that in the
system and contra specially
contributions from outside and the
situation afterwards to see if there's
any changes right so the research
questions here are who created maintains
and improves blast ok so both software
itself and as we'll see possible outside
improvement
what motivates those participants to
develop that software to reveal it to
others and possibly integrate it back
into the central code base and finally
how does it move to a more modular
architecture for the blast software
change the innovation system so i should
say the only clarifications or anything
just jump in and ask me all right so
what's the data in method here it is
looking at published papers and code and
so we've identified 11 improvements to
the blast system that were produced and
are relevant and we're doing
semi-structured interview interviews
with the creators of these systems okay
so we've been able to contact aid
projects out of the 11 and so we get
really good insight into the background
and the narratives of why these things
were created and how they were created
all right so little black background on
blast itself so blast was written out
and is maintained by in the NCBI which
is a center funded by the NIH all right
now so the NCBI was managing GenBank so
it was very natural place to kind of
think about how you develop code that
does lookups against that and and that
group actually intentionally gathered
trained scientists who also liked to
code and brought them into a group that
was able to have both in-house
biologists who are providing research
ideas and good scientific knowledge but
also understanding of algorithms and
statistics two important part of this
and doing that so Blass was initially
developed for youth value to do lookups
against GenBank relatively simple it was
also developed towards academic
reputation part of the idea and the
animating idea of NCBI was here was
going to be an environment where
software contributing scientists and
important is an environment with
software contributes itís are recognized
for that type of work and that meant
publishing academic papers something
that you know we're all relatively
familiar with plus an intention to
provide a service to the scientific
community and that's primarily what you
know how NIH views funding this type of
research
and so the people who developed the
original blast system then our authors
of those very highly cited papers all
chilled did some of the statistics and
other people were involved as well
alright so now what I'm going to do is
run through about just four cases of
outside improvements and just talk about
what they were and by people built them
all right and then we'll kind of pull
that back together and show a summary
slide that kind of explains the
innovation ecosystem and then tie that
back to reputation alright so the first
one we'll talk about is something called
woo blast which was code to implement
gap what's called gapped blast so you'd
imagine you doing optimal string
matching you have a big gap in the
middle it would be really nice to be
able to say you know I've got these
strings and match them even if there was
a gap so experiment with that gap so
originally blast didn't do that and that
was kind of one of the things that that
was fairly rapidly identified as
something that was worth doing one of
the original developers left in ncbi and
went to work in an academic career at
simpson lewis university in washington
and developed the gap blast idea still
in collaboration with some of the
scientists packet at ncbi but very
intentionally towards a tenure-track
appointment in a biology department okay
so this is now somebody who's building
code in that academic environment and so
very clearly was motivated by a desire
for tender which means building an
academic reputation all right so on
these are quotes said you know this was
my research project by which i would be
judged on my own merits for tenure and
he decided that he didn't want to
release the source code up so he didn't
want to reveal the source code for this
other was writing papers for fear that
my improvements would be consumed and
mike my case for tenure would be kind of
muddied by the belief that that code and
that idea belonged to other people all
right so just keep that one in mind a
very different situation here is what's
called digital compact blast and so
digital and compact were were computer
companies perhaps they are still and
this was about the time that I compact
bought digital but but the Alpha line
processes was still really important
okay and and so this was a port of blast
to that digital alpha platform and and
they basically use this to sell the
Alpha platform right so they knew that
by a life scientists increasingly needed
to run this computationally a heavy
piece of software and there wouldn't be
great if they could buy alpha equipment
to do that so they do the port
internally and then they produce some
benchmarks saying look into our hardware
really crunches numbers here so buy it
and will support this and so essentially
used to sell hardware now they talked
about the fact that it's quite expensive
to maintain those Forks they're giving
the code away so they can sell the
hardware so it's really a complementary
goods motivation and for them it really
made sense to then I try to push that
code back to ncbi because their
customers were more comfortable using
kind of mainline NCBI blast than they
were using the fork and maintaining that
fork every time NCBI comes out with a
new version is relatively expensive I
think this is something that we're
actually all relatively familiar with
all right slightly a different case was
a port of last two Mac OS 10 and this
was actually something that was
motivated I'm in a different way this
was created by a guy who worked at the
whitestone genetic institute during the
human genome program and had bought a
mac laptop had I was 10 on it liked it
wanted to use those tools on it it's all
kind of auto comp OS 10 is a UNIX
underneath so on the train but as we
know that's not enough that means i'll
actually compile and work but i saw on
the train on his one hour commute he
basically ported bioinformatics packages
to mac OS 10 and so he did that for both
fun and use value for himself and it was
maintained by it by that guy who wrote
the port actually maintained that
separately for a couple years he said
but Apple hears about this and decides
you know this is something relevant and
talk about another apple case in a
minute and so they eventually kinda they
provide some you know soft support to
that I think they eventually get in the
laptop maybe a trip out to cupertino and
and an introduction back to ncbi so that
he could push those changes back
and and eventually those changes do get
brought back and incorporated into blast
alright so the other case we'll talk
about at some length was something
called GPU blast and this one actually
comes after the change to the new
modular architecture right so this is a
group outside that now wants to
implement an update to blast and they
start with the new modular architecture
and and this these guys are straight-up
optimization science gasps they're
actually chemistry professors but
apparently chemist also do software
optimization and they they looked at it
and said you know blast the sort of
algorithm that has some parallelizable
parts and some interactive parts can we
use GPUs and here specifically the
Nvidia platform to optimize this and
drive it really quickly and other people
have tried this before but ended up with
slightly different results to make
people very nervous even though they're
statistically similar they're not
identical and so these guys do something
really identical results to the NCBI
blast just faster orders of magnitude
faster so they now maintain and still
maintain GPU blasts separately on their
on their website so even though they've
drawn from the modular the more Meldrick
code base they've implemented this
software maintain it on their website
and they've published a paper that
describes it when we interviewed them
that people was really crucial to why
they developed the code in the first
place so these are guys that are
motivated by academic credit and they
maintain that separate port because it
goes along with that paper and this is a
quote from them that says it says you
know the ideal for us would be that NCBI
comes to us right says let's write a
paper together and have them and have
all the users site that new paper from
now on so that's kind of that joint
paper that will allow us to indicate it
so let's work together to make sure we
design this in the best possible way
probably a joint paper right that would
be the ideal pregnant pause for us go be
the ideal for them because we're
bringing the reputation in the user base
of NCBI but also maintain their role in
having provided this code to the
academic community
recognition for that work which as we
know is a big part of the reputation
economy alright so those are the types
of cases you know you'll go in interview
people like that I really get the story
of how the thing was built try to
understand why it was built that way
alright and so a summary of that is here
so here we have blast in the middle this
is the non module of blast this is the
remodel rise blast each one of these are
improvements that as you see they all
start from the mainline blast and that's
actually pretty interesting right that
means this central thing provides an
ongoing persistent platform for people's
innovation there's a big difference
between the top half and the bottom half
and that's lines going back up to the
core innovation which is blast so all
these ones at the top here you can see
are similar to the power pc port there
should actually say OS 10 port those
also power pc port these are ones that
are motivated that are primarily our
academic i'm sorry primarily commercial
things that are associated with
complimentary good motivations the
group's down the bottom here are
primarily academics but you know
everyone jumped to a conclusion that is
totally based around reputation so let's
think about like what might be
explaining this difference where some of
them come back in and are folded back in
and others are maintained for a while
and then kind of drop off because a lot
of these projects just end up
disappearing from the website but they
don't like issue a retraction for the
paper or anything so there's this weird
relationship between the paper and
software alright so the first thing
would be kind of intentions you know the
people really want to integrate it does
ncbi want to integrate it and pretty
much all the people we talked to were
relatively comfortable with the idea of
integration although some obviously are
had some conditions based around that
right will integrate if there's a joint
paper but people maintain sort
understand the costs of maintaining that
code so intentions doesn't really
explain it because or at least
adequately because all kind of wanted to
and yet only some did right another
thing that came up was generalizability
basically the argument that things
should only get introduced back into the
core if it applies
to the widest group possible yeah
well I mean so so yeah so let me let me
check your getting us right so its
prototype in a specific scientific
research project that the software
improvement comes out of some bench work
where you need a different type of
software work and then from there having
been proved to contribute to science
then goes into the infrastructure that
the rest of the community might use the
academic reputation system and economy
and then how it specifically works in
different fields is really fascinating I
mean okay so are you saying that
priority is really crucial
you don't get yeah I mean we talked
about how communal sciences and that
scientists want to cooperate with each
other and one help each other
particularly on infrastructural
questions but we actually also know that
science is really competitive right and
that labs are competing with each other
and in this field where you're
describing is a highly competitive
environment and we know from the
literature like kind of data sharing
that people are very nervous about the
idea that this data set that I spent all
this time creating is going to be given
to everybody just because I got some
public money and then everyone will like
take the results that I would have mined
out of this data set so a very similar
thing I think happens with that sharp
down the road sure that motivation or is
it that doesn't matter I've got that
publish my paper on my research and
ideally I could call it a paper on my
instance of the software and yeah in
this study no but in another study yes
so in this study most of these
improvements were not driven by uh by
people who were doing a lot of science
for publication sorry a lot of like
domain science publication at the same
time so they would primarily focus on
software based contributions okay in
another paper the gym and I've done that
was at cscw 2011 we actually described
taxonomy of different software
contributions and the one that you're
describing there is this what we call a
parallel software practice where you're
doing your mainline science but you're
also writing code that might be useful
to others and then you're publishing a
paper to try and kind of create a
reputation hook for that paper too so
those motivations doesn't exist but we
didn't find them in this
cool so the second explanation is look
you only people have all sorts crazy
ideas for their like a specific research
projects and stuff but the only ones you
want to draw back into the main core are
the more generally applicable ideas and
i think that there's really something to
that idea i mean particularly if you
think of yourself as if you think of say
what happens in apache or whatnot people
do think about you know does this really
apply to everyone was just a really
specific edge case and it is relevant
but it doesn't really explain the GPU
GPU blast situation where that's a speed
up that could be useful to everybody
it's a relatively accessible commodity
hardware we can all buy GPUs and bang
them in our desktops or talk to our
research academic computing cluster get
GPU access and yet there's clearly a
motivational conflict that plays a role
in that too so another possible
explanation is just straight-up
integration costs that that there's not
a lot of reward to integration but
there's kind of high cost to it and so
pulling it back in is problematic and in
the modularity theory that's a really
crucial part of it right you have to
have stable api's so bring in that
module back into the system and
improving the whole system is easy so in
this case it doesn't really explain what
we found because projects were already
maintaining a merged environment they'd
already done that kind of expensive
integration because they wanted to keep
their project up to date with the core
project so they're already paying those
integration costs it doesn't really
explain it but more importantly the
modularity element doesn't seem to
explain it either which is also part of
the integration costs because all of the
cases that were integrated back in were
based on the non-modular blast and the
one case that we have in detail in two
other cases we have without interviews
are based on the non on the modular eyes
blast but still not incorporate it back
in so it seems like this idea that if
you make it more modular people will
make smaller changes and then contribute
them back and the whole system will
improve is not really bearing out in the
way that you expect in this specific
innovation system and so this finding is
kind of counter counter to what the
theory would predict
the modularity theory would say oh just
get easier to bring it back in but we
didn't see that yes which which paper um
so we um we are mean we asked the people
who wrote the software who then went on
to write a paper we asked them about the
story of the paper no we so in this case
the papers describe the software so it's
not that the papers no not in this case
although obviously the software is used
in other papers to generate results but
not in this case okay all right
okay we might we might talk talk do you
say nano hub so we said okay yeah I'd
love to talk about that's very
interesting okay yeah so it is written
written in 2007 available in 2008 so I
think is a great question I think that
we need to keep an eye on this I think
that these are these are results that
kind of drive towards the theorization I
do afterwards rather than kind of
proving for all time the modularity
can't help so yeah we need to keep look
at it what some you know certainly
people say that they like working with
the modernized version more so like that
part of the theory kind of works a bit
but it does seem that there is a
reputation question that drives in there
sort of a motivation question all right
so just kind of a quick summary of the
motivational results so at the top
you've got stuff that was driven by
academic credit and use value and
service provision am but no need to do
integration because these are developed
by NCBI right so that's kind of the core
stuff that seems to work relative well
stuff that's driven by complementary
goods and use value there seem to be
well motivated for developments very
well motivated for revealing because
that's a great way to sell hardware is
have pre code but also well motivated
for integration okay so we got
motivations you have complementary goods
and maintenance costs that seemed to
drive integration and motivate that for
the for the ones that are driven by
academic credit there's good motivations
for development the very clear
motivations for revealing at least the
binaries but also people tend to reveal
the source because after all that's what
you do in the academic reputation
accompanied you give it away but no
motivations for integration and that is
kind of the key finding here which is
that app academic reputation seems to
operate quite specifically in this
environment it motivates development and
revealing but seems to be counter
motivate cat seems to counter motivate
integration and that's really
problematic when you start to think
about how can we get scientists working
more collectively in the development now
financial so complimentary goods is
rewarded by money
right those and experiential motivations
seem well motivated to integrate their
either complementary or they're just
kind of independent so you neither you
had fun building it and then integrating
it doesn't take away the fun you had
building it and reducing maintenance
costs as a bonus there so let's kind of
jump back to the modularity theory for a
second and talk about how that
integration goes and so essentially it
seems like money talks and credit forks
which is to say if you're driven and
motivated by money and perhaps
experience as well then integration is
relatively at least in this environment
is relatively well motivated or at least
is possibly motivated as not I'm counter
and motivated and that's partially
because money is both divisible and
transferable all right so let's say Alex
and I you know get to know each other a
bit and alex has written a great system
and I come along and I improve it like
ten percent right let's say we're
running a private company and alex says
you know I think my customers would
really like that so I'll subcontracted
by that code that James wrote and you
keep selling your product but now we
have an agreement between us you keep
ninety percent of the money or profits
and I get ten percent right exactly so
it is not the case that just because
it's money things end up exactly equal
and nice right Apple takes thirty
percent of all peoples in app purchases
and they can do that because they have
power in the market right but the point
is that you can negotiate over that and
once you've negotiated you can do it so
all that money that you get we split it
up you keep 91 I take nine and but I
keep nine right because money can be
divided and transferred so we can talk
about who did what in the project all
right if it was enjoyment we don't even
have to do that because I had great
enjoyment doing it I make it available
to you and and there we go use values
the same right it's a really local and
immediately rewarded motivation but
academic reputation at least and
probably all reputation is different and
that's because when we have reputation
as a reward in a collective activity
reputation is not like money it's not a
substance right it's something that is
the result of other people
actions which means it has to be enacted
and it has to be enacted repeatedly for
it to actually have value and so you
know a classic enactment is letters of
support for tenure right but just the
day-to-day talking about who made what
contribution and who does good work is
the stuff of the academic economy which
means it's about relationships not about
objects in the same sense of money but
also means it's really hard to give away
so to continue the Alex and my
discussion if we agree that I my
contribution was about ten percent when
you give a talk you can say that every
time you can go orion or credit should
really go to James just like I did
started this one saying is joint work
with Jim herbst lab but realistically
people are talking to you they remember
they got the product from you they
started using it before I made my
contribution and you've got to change
their mind in a way that's much harder
than just giving me money right so
there's that and it's really hard to
split up like to make those distinctions
and to say oh this guy did that this
this group over here did this she did
this portion and so you know think about
that no objects tend to get associated
with their creators and in this
environment it seemed that people said
well people cite the original papers and
the original papers tend to be in better
publication environments than the
improvement papers and that's
problematic so it's kind of an analogy
of that I used to used to live in
Pittsburgh and I was at Carnegie Mellon
and when you're in when you're in New
Orleans you know what what's the river
in new orleans what's that very nice
what's the other one the mississippi
right so miss it what is the Mississippi
start right exactly so it's up here
right um or that's the city but actually
forty percent of the water that's
flowing past you in New Orleans comes
from the Ohio and a good forty percent
of that water comes from the Allegheny
which is up here in New York right but
obviously it all merges together at the
end but if people remember the mighty
mighty Mississippi and a similar thing
goes on when we merge objects in the
inner reputation economy the original
publications and the orig
creators I have this kind of sticky
ability or the reputation is relatively
sticky to that object and when we merge
other things in it seems to be
problematic and so this is something we
need to think about when we when we
think about how we're going to organize
collective activity in science
particularly co-op cooperative work on
software and that's because we need to
think about the objects of regards of
regard all right so just kind of summing
this up now and then I put it to
questions and conversation module of
modular theory largely developed in the
for-profit environment where money come
has its divisible and fungible at aspect
needs a little bit of kind of tweaking
in an environment where reputation is
the currency and that's because you can
make and integrate changes of limited
scope to improve the system okay this is
the idea you can build a better hard
drive you can build a better monitor and
kind of bring it in and then everyone
benefits from those changes to the
system but unless you also have modular
incentives whether give you a reason to
make reveal and integrate those changes
of a limited scope then you're not going
to get the innovation benefits from
modular systems that you expected in
another application is that incentives
can work differently at different stages
so you can have incentives at work for
development the work for revealing but
undermine integration you probably have
different kind of combinations of that
as well and reflecting on the idea that
modularity might be a good piece of
science policy it seems that funding a
modular refactoring is probably useful
right people did like working with the
modular code more but it's probably not
sufficient because it doesn't deal with
the questions of integration to the
extent that academic reputation is prime
motivation so then the question becomes
well alright so we could like improve
development and maybe improve
correctness by going more modular but
how do we improve integration and so
kind of some possible ways forward here
and we know we're just starting to think
about these is could you have could you
do this through some new policies and so
you know people talk about well we're
gonna have a policy if you write a paper
and it's got coding it you have to
release that code
and that's great okay hey that's hard
enough and it's kind of controversial
but that's great we might end up with a
lot of forked code out there so to speak
so should we also say that if you really
want to get ideal credit for this that
you shouldn't only release this code but
you should work with the other people
and then integrate it it's kind of
tricky right might work we got this
publication lever to do a lot with it
how do you make the people who aren't
publishing that paper want to integrate
it with that and then ideas on that
would be interesting to me perhaps you
can fund integration as a primary
activity and a little bit more hope for
this at the moment we primarily fund
infrastructure developers to write code
and make it available right we can kind
of tweak that idea and say you know you
guys aren't the apache httpd project
committee right you're actually the
Apache foundation and your goal is to
create an innovation ecosystem not to
produce code for other people right so
you become stewards of that and I talk
to people that like supercomputing
centers about our kind of kind of
interested but it's been very different
than what they've been funded to do
before which is have FTEs that right
code right there's a whole different
skill set but one that I think quite
interesting but we really must get at
this question of how joint development
is going to really reflected in the
academic reputation system how do we
account for this and I'm at a school of
information and so I like to think of
this as an information problem or at
least make that argument my colleagues
which is this information about
contributions and so let's talk more
about this study right now I'm just
going to draw out pull back just the
touch and talk about kind of a little
bit of a wider piece of work that we're
doing and so our overall coming back to
our overall interested in scientific
software we really start to think about
how you do improve motivations for kind
of all five of these functions within
the scientific software ecosystem so
development of ealing integration and
also long-term support and maintenance
and one of the ways we're looking at
doing that is building what we're
calling the scientific software network
map and so imagine if you had all the
papers and you knew for each paper what
pieces of software
it had used to build its science and so
that's really getting at the question
you asked before about how was that
software used to produce the science am
and who wrote that and then for each one
of those you can look at what software
that software was built on and you could
also ask where did the contributions
towards that piece of software come from
right and so now we're talking about not
only building bibliometric connections
between the papers and the pieces of
software that we use for them but
building sued over blue metric
connections out all the software that
was used in those and kind of dividing
up those contribution lies yes there's a
lot of software inside laboratory
instruments and that went in another
paper we did we went to looked at with
interview people who wrote papers and
found out all the software they used you
know and really nailed hard on them
they're like so we get the data back
from the lab and I'm like hey what's up
what are they using the lab well you
know it's a chroma graph what's up was
in the chroma graph who wrote it and so
you know i can give you the reference
for that one too it's quite interesting
a lot of those a lot of thats accounted
for while we sell the hardware software
goes with it i think people in the room
okay I don't know the answer to this
yeah there still seems to be a lot of
shoehorning and reputation to the things
that make reputation
it's all about the paper in the citation
that works on the paper and just
wondering where aha so one one of the
concerns that they have them an approach
like this is that the lag time between
research and publication being so
involved that if you were to quickly
search ignore the current reputation
system and just look at it purely a
software update one of you would that
mean to a different flow these are the
units of sight ability that aren't
papers as yeah but modules or visas or
disabilities I mean yes I think it's
really important to think you know the
fact that your software gets included in
a distro might be a really nice thing
for a software computing science to use
to make the argument to this is a her
colleagues that they've made a
contribution but you are eventually
going to then have to just a question of
indirectness because you then you've got
to make the argument that the distro
drives science right that drives good
scientific results because at the moment
when I took scientific software
developers like saying the cyber
infrastructure space they might count
their users but then their funders are
like yeah but what innovative science
did those users do and they're like I'm
going on a now I'm going to contact like
100 users and make that case now so yes
I think we can have sizable units that
aren't papers particularly I mean one of
the things we're doing and talk about it
two secs real quickly is looking at
citation looking at that question so
yeah
yeah well I think it's an open question
how much of open source these days is
written by the same academics people
there's written my academics yeah
reputation in open source doesn't seem
to have this integration problem right
and I think that's really curious and
needs more thinking my initial kind of
thoughts on that are that bad reputation
is relatively internal okay what really
matters is what the other people in the
project think about your contributions
and that that seems like a finer-grained
decision that people are making whereas
academic reputation is primarily
primarily of use when you're addressing
audiences that don't know your work that
carefully right so you become the people
who like use the code or work with you
closely they know how you do your work
it's making your case to be or you know
external reviewers we're like
bibliometrics starts to play a role so I
think there's something about the
different audiences of reputation but
I'd love to think about that more so let
me just finish by saying that the work
the other work that we're doing this
area so one thing we're doing is
instrumentation right we're so we're
going out and we're trying to help
scientists instrument their software so
that it reports their own use small okay
and so that's both with changes to their
code but also developing formats and
standards by which they can provide it
what do you think about scientific
software is it shows up just comes off
people's websites so there's not even
any like top ten app lists or sauce
which download statistics as useless as
those are in some ways at least they're
there and create information cascades so
that people kind of coalesce on good
bits of software science that just comes
off different web servers and no one
really knows so we're working with
different communities SP grid we can
start working to the our community to
try and get some more of this
instrumentation and talk about how we
could do this that's one thing second is
we're going to work on developing the
reporting infrastructure for science
funding agencies so when they fund a
scientific piece of scientific software
development how does that community
report its success so basically asking
them to look at its users ask them to
look at the
is better but really taking advice from
the Apache community that uses dope
description of a project to create a
distributed catalogue that can will be
kept updated because one thing I'm not
doing is a survey of all software
they'll be outdated next next month not
doing that finally I want to do an
analysis of published papers in two ways
one which is looking at artifacts
created in papers may be things that are
left over from the software that allow
us to kind of understand what software
they used that I think hopeful but also
limited and then looking at citation
practices and this is what we're kind of
knee-deep in at the moment which is
looking at whose sites software when
what different types of citations are
there for software and one question we
can ask there is doo doo doo newer
papers for software like you updated
papers actually end up being cited order
people cite the original one moment so
that would be interesting thing so I
think one of the things that maybe the
scholarly communication group here will
be interested in us talking about some
of those announced publish papers so
that's it for me very much welcome
discussion questions
so flat for example into this thing and
you know how much more money ah I don't
I have thought about doing it I i think
it probably is probably worthwhile as we
develop this data set out more both
tracking and what happen tinues to
happen and kind of putting a number on
that we haven't done that yet we've
relied on the people who know the code
well to tell us that they did it well
and people down the track but it's
slightly worth checking right because if
it's not more modular then oh wait we
really know yeah I great thanks to what
extent do you know so much about this
but to what extent are there parallels
to the notion pedo citation especially
mention native an ability or there is a
paper which is very highly cited but
then there's the issue of contributions
where you're not going to software
you're contributing data into yeah I
mean I think there's probably a
relatively similar phenomenon happening
that I mean there are some similarities
there are lots of similarities between
data and software they're kind of
alternative academic contributions
they're increasingly important they are
kind of small units that are best in
combination listings role similar
software is a little bit different in
that I think it probably needs more
maintenance that the ecosystem around
the software changes more over time and
so you've got to kind of keep that
software functioning within that
structure of dependencies although the
more i talk to people who deal with data
the more those other questions come up
so i've been trying to talk to the data
site people but nobody i haven't spoken
only one who's is found anyone yet just
kind of really dealt with this question
of the people integrate these data
contributions the general thinking is
you collected the data you wrote a paper
based on it and now you're going to get
the data in and doesn't cost anything
and it has public benefits the idea that
I'm sure that there's any people who
just collect data and have that to be a
good scientific notation perhaps there
should be everything should talk about
that a lot actually kind of him I find
the idea of healing advantages of paper
and the guy that spoke to in Copenhagen
able to come to is actually bundling up
the virtual machine so you get the paper
as this and unpacked there's the data
there's a software you can run the data
through this offer get the result you
see the paper and so that's seems like a
long ways to go but you like a software
is embedded in so not only publish a
paper published data set but also
because the gem generally speaking we
have multiple series of processing
stages right like a river day lots of
stuff comes together that's just sort of
sorry yeah the executable paper I think
I mean it's um when your focus is
reproducibility it makes a lot of sense
perhaps if your focus is transparency so
that I'll learn what you did it also
makes a lot of sense but leaving a site
that kind of recursive problem of
keeping virtual machines going if your
goal is collective innovation so I can
build on what you did then kind of
packaging and freezing things as they
were three years ago might not be the
best basis for Quentin innovation right
because that that code can bid rots with
respect to the rest of the ecosystem and
now I want to build on top of the little
problematic so so there's a lot to think
about that is at least you get better
reproducibility and transparency right
be nice stop it's one goal yep
so that and then you know yeah I I think
it's really at the moment we set aside a
sign this you know be nice if you open
source your code right and what we
really and then there's some group that
some people who think the better that's
what we want for reproducibility there's
some people who think that's enough to
get collaboration right and in my mind
it's not nearly enough to get
collaboration and in fact it could be
problematic so we have another paper
where you look at will call different
logics of correctness in software so
that's the best of you three and they're
a little bit freaky if you're a software
engineer okay but first one is I wrote
it myself I know it really well right
second one is somebody else wrote it
lots of people use it I'm sure it's
correct that's a basically a version of
the many is Michael but I've shallow I
can the third one is and it's relatively
unique to science which is independent
implementations and my theory tell me
what results it should get and it gives
me those results that was up really as
silly as it sounds is it sounds really
celebrate you like it given what i
expect therefore i think it's correct
well no because independent
implementations and this kind of
multiple dependent pieces of theory tell
you what to expect and that helps to
iteratively shape you're thinking it's
very different than you know writing a
test suite to test it
up here but if we take if we just talk
about open source their code then we're
essentially saying take code that has a
logic of correctness that I wrote it
myself I know really well i know its
limitations i know what parameters will
work with it make the available of
people as open source and then the other
people come along there by logic to to
it which is his own source lots of
people use it must have been checked out
really well and then we could get into
you know series correctness products and
and that's I think a Down some people
I'm really thinking that carefully about
with just getting people to release more
code so the archiving archiving is a
solution thank you differentiate hint
you just figure competence you also
regarding focus sourcing the method of
documentation any people to document
code is really difficult but if it's a
low barrier to entry I just published it
out there so you can look at it again
it's kind of a digression no no I I
think chocolate in going back to that
your question for your point about data
site i think that there that's another
parallel which is without a diva said
not just being a static snapshot in time
but of a data data collection looking at
sky surveys or at night you know what
birth data we're constantly improving it
the data and your interpretation of that
data based on your software both of
these things are evolving over time and
so how important is that at that
Junction is snapshotting this is the
data that i was looking at and this is
the top without easy to interpret that
data at that moment in time versus
saying this
approaches I took in when you come back
to three years later the different than
the Opera House I mean I think that that
is question that's really worth pursuing
because I don't know that there's a kind
of specific just one answer that
question I think it's going to be quite
a contingent I really like the idea that
if i use a set of digital so i can skies
that here came back if i use it i use it
in some code i write next cute wallpaper
would it be nice if that data set and
told me the set of citations that I
ought to use rights can be one for the
button set up a framework everyone for
someone who implemented that one for
somebody who actually collected the data
in the field that contributed just that
little small piece of data and that's
that's feasible right that's that
reduces the work for the authors there's
a nice kind of technical solution so if
you do that with day we also go to
software so what we're trying to do at
the moment with our is each our package
have implements the citation function
which is meant to tell you what citation
the author wants for this so we're going
through all the packages and finding a
poor a how much people use that and be
could we analyze the art history file so
that when somebody writes some code with
are you know they can just go kind of
like meta citation so you're all the
citations well packages you use and then
all the citations for all the dependent
code that I package use those are all
this data is available right and then
gives you like the seven sites as you
like your easter egg at all where you
get the wall
there you go softwear a good I haven't
yet i'm looking forward to knowing more
about that that's not where any for a
new critical mass observations that you
needed they tell you the training i'll
tell you the call i just try their
complicated oh really lastly an
exception yeah i love song so any other
you know the last questions thanks